welcome to the fourth week of this
course by now you've seen forward
propagation and back propagation in the
context of a neural network with a
single hidden layer as well as logistic
regression and you've learned about
vectorization and when it's important
initialize the weights randomly if
you've done the past company's homework
we've also implemented and seen some of
these ideas work for yourself so by now
you've actually seen most of the ideas
you need to implement a deep neural
network what we're going to do in this
week is take those ideas and put them
together so that you'll be able to
implement your own deep neural network
because the following exercise is longer
and just has a bit more work going to
keep the video so this week short as you
get through the videos a little bit more
quickly and then have more time to do a
significant programming exercise at the
end which I hope will leave you having
built a deep neural network that you
feel proud of so what is a deep neural
network you've seen this picture for a
literacy regression and you've also seen
new networks sort of a single hidden
layer so here is an example of a neural
network with two hidden layers and in
your network with five hidden layers we
should say that logistic regression is a
very shallow model whereas this model
here is a much deeper model and shallow
versus depth is a matter of degree
so neural network of a single hidden
layer this would be a two layer neural
network remember when we count layers in
neural network we don't count the input
layer we just count the hidden layers as
was the output layer so this would be a
two layer neural network is so quite
shallow but not as shallow as logistic
regression technically logistic
regression is a you know one layer
neural network but over the last several
years
dai on the machine learning community
has realized that there are functions
that very deep neural networks can learn
that shallower models are often unable
to although for any given problem it
might be hard to predict in advance
exactly how deep a neural network you
will want so it would be reasonable to
try logistic regression
one and two hidden layers and view the
number of hidden layers is another hyper
parameter that you could try a variety
of values of and evaluate on holdout
cross validation data or all your
development set say more about that
later as well let's now go through the
notation we're used to describe deep
neural networks here is a one two three
four layer neural network with three
thin layers and the number of units in
these hidden layers are I guess five
five three almond and it's one output
unit so the notation we're going to use
is going to use capital L to denote the
number of layers in the network so in
this case L is equal to four and so
that's the number of layers and we're
going to use n superscript L to denote
the number of notes or the number of
units in they are lowercase L so if we
index this the input as layer 0 this is
layer 1 this is layer 2 this is layer 3
and this is layer 4 then we have that
for example n 1 that would be this the
first isn't layer would be equal to 5
because we have 500 units there for this
one without that n 2 the number of units
in the second sitting there is also
equal to 5 n 3 is equal to 3 and n 4
which is n capital L this number of
units is this number of output units is
equal to 1 because here our capital L is
equal to 4 and we're also going to have
here therefore the input layer n 0 is
just equal to n X is equal to 3 okay so
that's the notation we use to describe
the number of nodes we have in different
layers so each layer L also also going
to use a L to denote D
observations in there l so we'll see
later that in for propagation you end up
computing al as the activation G applied
to ZL and then perhaps the activations
index by the layer l as well and then
we'll use WL to denote you know the
weights for computing the values VL in
the ARL and similarly VL that's used to
compute ZL finally just to wrap up on
the notation the input features are
called X but X is also the activations
of layer 0 so a 0 is equal to X and the
activation of the final layer a capital
L is equal to Y hat so a superscript
square bracket capital L is equal to the
predicted output to prediction y hats of
the neural network so you now know what
a deep neural network looks like as well
as the notation will use to this drive
and to compute with teeth networks I
never introduced a lot of notation in
this video but if you ever forget what
some symbol means we've also posted on
the course website a notation sheet or a
notation guide that you can use to look
up what these different symbols means
mix elect to describe what forward
propagation in this type of network look
like let's go into the next video